[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
at what is on the front page it's time
then to see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and broadcaster
Jenny cleeman and the associate editor
for politics at the Daily Telegraph
Christopher hope and welcome to both of
you as ever we start with the front
pages and as deaths from strip a
continue the eye reports that the
government may be forced to buy in extra
antibiotics to protect school children
from infection
the mirror focusing on the grief of the
family of one five-year-old girl who
died with the headline strep a took my
princess
meanwhile moan alone is the Metro's
headline after Tory Pierre baroness Moon
announces she's taking leave of absence
from the Lords because the pressure over
her alleged profiting from a PPE company
awarded government contracts during the
covert pandemic
the guardian also makes that story its
front page lead with more accusations it
says
and with Britain facing a massive wave
of strikes in the coming days and weeks
the financial times reports that Rishi
sunak is under pressure to speed up his
planned legislation to crack down on
Industrial action
telemail claims that labor is taking
millions of pounds from the unions going
on strike a situation the paper says
leaves the party in Hawk to the unions
and the Daily Star looks ahead to the
looming belt of freezing weather cold
enough it says to even make Amanda
Holden put a coat on
I'm sure she wears a coat in Winter
anyway a reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch the program and our guest so let's
go to Jenny cleeman and Christopher hope
and Jenny let's kick off them with the
guardian they say they've got an
exclusive more accusations against this
Tory Pier Michelle moan what exactly are
they saying here because obviously she's
asked for a leave of absence hasn't she
from the House of Lords
she has this is very much the guardian
story they broke the the initial story
uh linking her lobbying to a company
that received a 20 million pound uh
contract in 2020 which the guardian
alleges she profited from she and her
family profited from uh this story today
uh links her to another company a
company that Michelle moan was lobbying
governments uh to receive contracts for
uh lateral flow testing and according to
the guardian she lobbied really
aggressively she was given a warning for
how aggressive her lobbying was I think
there's no suggestion that any contracts
in this particular case uh were given
out to the company
um but this is a very bad situation for
lady mon a friend of of David Cameron
the original story uh this PPE company
uh which she has been linked to was
awarded a 200 million pound contract at
a time when the government we were
putting our Blind Faith in the
government to do whatever it took to
help us and Via these VIP Lane certain
companies were given preferential access
to uh to public money and the accusation
that lady moan was was gouging money
public money at a time of great crisis
is is a very very serious one the
conservative whip has has not been
removed from her she has taken a leave
of absence whether or not that is to
avoid scrutiny remains to be seen
and I suppose we have to
um realize all of this is slightly done
with retrospective eyes Christopher you
know there was a global Scramble for
just about everything PPE you know
ventilators you name it but if we look
at the the Metro as well monolone their
headline
um certainly she has become a focal
point for the opposition
um and their accusations on VIP channels
for procurement and wasted government
cash effectively
yeah I'm I'm not what I'm not someone
who gets um televised about this story
at the time
um the gun was trying to find any PP to
protect us they had no idea about the
the virulence of code 19. um they they
are literally a union leader phoning me
up saying that I know somebody in the
cabin office who could help with a a
manufacturer near Derby I think who
wanted to provide PPE for the government
or try and work out a way of making it
with their Factory it was quite common
at that time to find anybody who knew
anybody to try and get the whole
National effort into creating PP because
the supplies have been cut off from
China now whatever Michelle moan diddle
didn't do we'll learn that as as this
plays out
um but I think there's a lot of people
judging It Through The Eyes of now when
we thank goodness are seeing Kobe in the
rear view mirror one of the time
ministers were using these VIP Lanes to
try and cut through the red tape to get
PPE made and get it to protect people
who needed it and that was the point of
it but there's no question if anything
if anything was done wrong here and it
must be looked at I think the guardian
is going after it because they're not
really a big fans of business and big
fans of entrepreneurs like Michelle moan
um and she's I mean she's I wouldn't say
she's exactly
um someone close to any anyone in
government at the moment I mean Shiki
was in touch with ministers but in terms
of her being an active Tory Pier
um she hasn't spoken as John Craig was
saying since March 2020 she voted last
in April the 26th this year she's very
rarely seen around Parliament and I'm
there nearly every single day I think
it's it's more there's an agenda here
the guardian is pushing that's fine
that's the guardian but I think that the
time it was quite understandable why
anyone was using any way to get things
done to try and save lives yeah Jenny
quickly you've been shaking your head
I'm just astonished that that's
Christopher's take on all of this this
isn't about contracts being awarded to
hastily this is about somebody
profiteering making 20 million pounds
it's alleged from a company
pushing on onto onto ministers and this
is a company that provided aprons that
couldn't be used by the NHS and masks
are vastly inflated prices this is not
about being entity business this is
about being anti-corruption and I would
say good on the guardian for for
continuing to to push on all of this
um at a time when I I don't think we've
forgotten the terrible things that
happened during covid and this needs
more scrutiny than ever at a time when
the public purse is so completely
squeezed I'm not judging her case Jenny
at all I'm really saying that there's a
context that is sometimes missed there's
no question if if wrongdoing is it
happened here if she did profiteer then
clearly she has to be exposed and she'd
children die all wrong doing that'll be
played out in the public sphere I'm just
saying to you there's a contact okay
okay Christopher I'm going to stay with
you and go to the Ft now
um the Prime Minister Under Pressure
they suggest to speed up anti-strike
legislation real concerns now about
unions getting together on ambulance
workers for example the impacts on the
hospitality industry with rail strikes
and anybody else trying to get to work
so what's the suggestion here
well since in the 2019 general election
the toys were elected on a Manifesto
pledge to quotes require the minimum
service operates during transport
strikes now what's happened since then
Kobe has happened the Ukraine wars
happened but what hasn't happened is
concerned about the way unions might be
agitating particularly now with with
double digit inflation a a bill was
introduced called transport strikes
minimum service levels Bill back in
October and nothing's happened and lots
of Tories are telling me why on Earth as
a government sitting on its hands
because it has a Manifesto pledge to try
and bring about new ways to try and
force companies to be able to buy their
minimum service during strike action it
hasn't happened yet and yet again we're
seeing for many original act almost
hiding in number 10 and not doing
anything so this story near front page
is the Ft isn't really soon act doing it
it's pressure from MPS on him to do it
and lots of puzzlement I think amongst
stories I speak to that the government
isn't doing more in the front foot to
try and get Britain working again and
and find a way to navigate through this
um what should be a blip of double digit
inflation not a long-term issue well
front foot how then I mean being the
people to bring groups together to
actually do the negotiating is that
Christopher just quickly is that is that
what you're suggesting
well well briefly Mark Harper and others
hide behind the fact is an employer's
employee rail but there is there is a
legislation that can be done there to to
try and force these these
um these public uh services to do a
better service for for consumers okay
Daily Mail is making a real political
Point obviously um Jenny labor and Hawk
to the unions who are crippling Britain
um always talking about financing Etc of
that party
um but there is a you know a real fear
Now isn't there for those who are ill
it's already difficult to get an
ambulance you know if you're old and you
have a fall it feels like you're on your
own on those dates and you know the
question is there's been a lot of
support for people Everyone Knows
inflation's terrible they know they've
had years of austerity in terms of pay
you know at what point does public mood
slightly change do you think
and I think you know the basic
functioning of the country is under
threat basic things we took for granted
that if you ring an AM ring for an
ambulance someone will take the call
then a nurse will look after you that if
you post a letter it will arrive that
your your train will eventually arrive
these things we can no longer take for
granted that if you go on a flight that
your bag may be there to to meet you at
the end of it I think there's different
amounts of public sympathy for for
different Strikers I think people are
pretty Fed Up of the rail strikes now I
think we would all like uh uh a pay rise
in line with um inflation but of course
that is going to increase and prolong
inflation when you have things like
paramedics call handlers saying that
part of the reason why they're striking
is because the core handlers are going
home in tears feeling feeling
traumatized by the fact that they have
left people without ambulances for hours
on end you can understand that they are
striking also for minimum levels of
service as well as pay perhaps there's
more sympathy for them but when we see
the the I think it's an extra 12 days of
rail strikes going on and on when the
train service even when there's no
strikes it is poor enough as it is I
think patience is really running thin
yeah and um we're waiting to hear about
uh border four staff as well you know
one suggestion I think elsewhere in the
telegraph suggesting that flights could
be canceled
um contingencies are already being made
we're told by the cabin office I mean
just very quickly Christopher that that
really will test people's patients
because we have to remember two years of
like tier four you know lockdown people
are quite excited about being able to
see family this year
I know I've been looking at some archive
stuff this week I mean this time a year
ago next week um Boris Johnson said we
sure work from home I mean you know if
you forget how recently that was we're
trying to forget about Kobe because
we're natural optimists and I would say
generally we want to move on with our
lives but this is like you know we are
trying to find Freedom here and these
unions are not finding that way and I
think there's there's a you know there's
double digit inflation as Jenny says
correctly it will just fuel inflation
further if big numbers of posts that
have receive this kind of leveling
increase and that's why we all have to
hunker down and get through this
together yes and I think one of the
ambulance unions today suggesting it's
not just about pay it's about
unacceptable working conditions because
there's just not enough staff as we know
that's across the board is it not anyway
lots more still to come including
another Health worry for many of us the
Daily Mirror leading with this tragic
story strip a took away my princess bed
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again
journalist and broadcaster Jenny cleeman
and the associate editor for politics at
the Delhi Telegraph Christopher hope
welcome back to both of you
um Jenny I'm going to come to you again
first if you don't mind simply because I
know one of your children's been in a
class with strep a with scarlet fever
effectively so take us through the
coverage tonight the Daily Mirror one
very sad tale and the eye talking about
antibiotics if they can be got hold of
the mirror has an interview with the
father of Stella Lily mccorkindale uh
who's he's the father of the ninth uh
Strep strep a victim uh in the UK to die
of the illness he's calling on uh her
schoolmates to all go on on antibiotics
um there were several cases of scarlet
fever in my son's class we had a warning
uh just over 10 days ago and then on
Friday I had to go and pick my son up
from school he was Ill those of you who
know me well will hear from my voice I
haven't been very well there is clearly
something horrible going around that
children don't have much immunity to
that some adults don't have much
immunity to I mean the eyes story I have
to say I find this coverage from the eye
quite alarmist
um they were saying that the current
stockpile it says the current stocks
pile may not be enough to cover
widespread use this is according to
Whitehall sources that have spoken to
the eye but the Department of Health
says there are no supply issues so I
would question whether it was very
responsible to leave with the headline
our correspondent in the Northwest
certainly spoke to pharmacists who said
are you joking we can't we have had no
deliveries of um I think you mentioned
penicillin today we can't get hold of it
the dream of giving it
um you know just in case which is the
suggestion in some classes like you're
like your sons you know maybe impossible
so you know once again you know to
scramble to get medicine at this time of
year it's um you know this this really
does worry people doesn't it Christopher
given given really that the strains
already on the NHS I know and also in
this case this Daily Mirror article this
excellent article about describe this
Father Robert mccorkindale he took his
daughter to the hospital three times in
three days before she was admitted and
but by then it was too late and she died
so you'd hope really that I mean strep a
even for me and I'm a dad of three of my
children are need grown up now I know I
real idea what it was
um there's the suggestions it's growing
because children were kept apart and
they couldn't have this natural immunity
and so it might all go back to the
lockdowns we've been through over the
past past two years but I think this is
all really vital everyone reads about
this as parents they know what it is as
Jenny's saying find out what's wrong and
any worries uh act on it I mean the idea
of more more antibiotics is maybe not a
good thing unless they are required
that's what I say all but I'd say about
that because we need to have lessen our
bodies than more yeah absolutely yeah
and it does stuff to your
um overall immunity does it not if you
take too many antibiotics I'm going to
very quickly show the other papers we're
going to talk about uh one is Abby
families the news that the k in Queen
consort and Prince William will attend
Kate's Carol service on the day that
Harry and Megan's last three Netflix
episodes come out they have also been
out and about tonight at a diplomatic
core event and also the Daily Star which
takes us to the weather which is next
snow on the way they say certainly cold
lovely to see you both not cold in here
um Christopher hope and Jenny cleeman
thank you both thank you